hello and welcome to the final Cora
v-log and most likely the most viewed
one that we're going to do um two very
important people I think came out and
confess their love um ma co and Bolin in
the middle of that machine finally said
they love each other I know I mean I
thought that was really amazing and it's
like it's if only there was like two you
know and I gotta say Korra and Asami
BFFs forever I don't know they are
encouraging yeah I mean yeah cup friends
do it all the time right they just take
a little vacay together and no the big
deal is I hold hands with you all the
time all the time I just assumed they
were fresh skip we actually skip
together and nobody gives us weird looks
at all well because we don't do that in
public but you know but in sight which
is even more norm in the privacy of our
own home where we come to play with our
toys now that's got to take ahold of me
so okay so you know like most of the log
is just gonna be talking about like half
a minute of the episode so well let's
just go over the quick overview of of it
in general I mean honestly this is this
is a good finale it especially the first
half it's pretty much just all taking
down this giant robot uh which is okay I
keep thinking of Kentucky Fried movie
now giant robots which you know on the
one hand thinking like season two was
kinda you have big things battling each
other but I like the idea they're still
small too trying to get inside this
thing it is very anime I mean like the
mecca's and stuff like that I mean it's
very big Oh wind-up III kept joking
they're gonna build like I could think
of Evangelion I was like is there gonna
be a new republic city 3 or something
like Tokyo 3 what so the first half of
this is just battling this machine it's
wonderfully done I mean just uh
comparison they're controlling it it's
trying to swat at them like flies and
stuff like that um and people try to
make sacrifices no you can't you know so
I can go go but then that person comes
back your engine all these things I
could've done without that actually that
yeah got old but
are you still doing some good so what
when did he make friends with the honey
badgers some honey badgers yeah or do
they just not give a shit like no no
it's like how did he control them to
come around the other end cuz moving
forward I can see cuz it's like they
would want to almost get away so they
fill him to stop his singing and they
miss baby I don't know but regardless uh
so a Kabir's destroyed or stopped I
should say and then Corrick I don't like
a dummy when she has her down on the
ground I mean clearly should like metal
Benson handcuffs or something and she's
like you know you've lost Kabir and
she's like I'm really not sure out goes
gets the gotchas I take you're out
bitches and but khorog but they would
have been able to create a new spirit
porn yes so Korra through whatever and
Kamiya dick one woman with a giant gun
that big let's admit it that was kind of
high
she's just like it's just the most
ridiculous over-the-top it's like this
this little tiny woman to like next to
this trigger and this guns like the size
of the Empire State women wait just a
little poor there at the end of him like
this with this guy feels like a bully
Tunes cartoon it wasn't it was a
roadrunner so uh but yeah court uses her
powers to one accord about a little tiny
umbrella and be like so opens up the
spirit where this noosphere portal um
Julie and very could use a thing yeah do
the thing I put in my face with some
bees like you know you need context with
it I was like I know exactly what I did
this is if you don't get it you don't
deserve to get um and as if they tie the
knot and at the very end everything
seems to be okay everyone's cool and
korra and asami say they need a vacation
they decide to go to the spirit world
holding hands looking at each other's
eyes and it ends right there
little heart closes it out um it's it's
just so nice um okay so for me there's
gotta be two ways to come at this and I
usually hate doing that like we have to
we go two ways but there really is in my
opinion for this um because on the one
hand it's like if I'm right I think this
is like the first bisexual character
main lead in a kids show ever
I I don't know if they know that they
had psyche here I don't think they were
bisexual the whole time
I think Marco turns them see honesty
Baca was so bland I'm talking about
Laura
that yeah oh he's oh he turned her yeah
yeah mama ko Mok Oh turns the two that
they both dated that is true not as they
both did this is like George Costanza
and his girlfriend becomes lesbian
amputee yeah you got wonder what's going
through his mind now like wow I turn to
two women lesbian okay but all I think I
need to move out of town and rethink my
life goals I never thought about before
maca in the end it's still all about
poor mock so alright so so on the one
hand yet this is a huge step and I
anyone that reads like my facebook and
stuff like that knows I'm very Pro gay
rights and I I hate the fag and my huge
stuff we mean it's about all you're
gonna get out of a show on it go sissy
says but the fact I'm really good at all
you know the Japanese are watching this
like yeah and and lip whiz the tentacles
oh that's it oh hey we did this shit on
Sailor Moon 20 years Oh cute little
Americans so everyone's talking about it
it's like this huge whose thing like
your nose like oh the best finale ever
unbelievable um and for the people that
have a problem with it well yeah and see
em there's a few I've seen leave the
occasional comment on my facebook that's
like fucking stupid we're not okay so
ease alone no the funny thing about is
there cuz like I mean we'll try think
what angle to come out and because it is
a huge step it is real
great uh and it's it's wonderful to see
this happen I hate the fact that we live
in a time where it's like this is a big
deal like oh my god can you believe a
showed in appraiser Zamunda like 20 it
may be even more years ago every year I
see one at least one lesbian anime yeah
you're a moon I mean yeah right is it
normally set in place yeah what else can
tell the moon is yeah a kid show in
Japan right I mean is they like seeing
camp like adults can watch it too but it
seemed primarily as like a kid just kids
instead I don't know I never watched
Sailor Moon in Japan the the general
feeling I get is a it's a teen show huh
okay so but but definitely for younger
audiences it's the kind of a teen show I
think even though it's running on
Nickelodeon and there's that but there's
definitely been like a guy I've heard
about like other shows where it's like
they're side characters that are like
gay or bisexual or something like that
but I don't I've never seen a mail order
in the industry I definitely not know
the sisters in Japan they'll just do it
no no not about like in America like Oh
in America oh no in America we got all
sorts of hang-ups yeah so but I'm
healthy I think be not doing your sister
hang up despite twincest I'm very
healthy
uh you know some anyone that doesn't
watch the gravity falls be along who's
gonna be like what the fuck was rocking
about look up gravity falls and twincest
people find out I have some talked about
with you um but yeah okay so all of that
is wonderful all is that all that is
fantastic
uh but at the same time I'm looking at
this and the first thing that pops in my
head is this was this felt like a
gimmick for good cause because outside
of a couple conversations that they had
together which you called your like and
they say I can't believe I called this
at the beginning of season 3 oh no and
there's even that said no I do remember
there's one point where Asami even kya
says I forget the exact line but some
along the lines of like you know she's
kind of coming out a bit but not
directly saying it but my thought was
well okay I mean it's that might be
something but I mean like I don't think
they're gonna go all the way with it
because they're just they're not doing
it they're not developing it they're not
going into it and then at the
well it exactly that is your just
cumshots that we can be like I would
thought gimmicky and then oh they just
brought it like it was only subtle hints
and brought out the last second what are
you gonna let the network with the
talking sponge you're gonna run it on
that no no okay that lets you well I met
that's why it's gonna get too so on the
one hand I'm like well this is great
that happens and we have this main
character but from a storytelling
perspective uh just imagine for a minute
everything else is the same everything
about these characters everything
happens exactly the same make us ah me a
guy and story-wise ask yourself if this
makes any sense
it's it's not bad there's nothing wrong
with it but at the same time I'm like
where did that come from like this is
the last image of the show we ever see
and it's like oh no don't you know it
was about these two coming together it
was you know and don't get me wrong
there's definitely like I want to see
more of this like I if they do like what
they do with Zuko's mom well because
that was unanswered and they do it in
the comics and it allows two coming
together the whole series know is it
probably the logical last final step if
you want those two to be in love if you
want your main characters some if you
want your main character to somehow end
in love which is its own great debate
because now even though it's a lesbian
story you could argue oh so now she
needs a woman to be a success like but
you know yeah that is the only logical
step left she's gone through everyone
else Bolin's got um what's your face
it's early in the morning sisters you
know like we're like the table to be
fair we have always forgotten her name
morals aren't there the lawyers I even
remember Asami's cuz it's all over the
internet everybody gather them um that
person anyway everybody's got somebody
and and varrick is vaca knows how much
account though but that they went
through Malcolm ACOs used goods he bet
he's packages he's like that chewed
piece of gum you leave under the seat so
that pretty much leaves only those two
but nobody's vain character okay bye
know what
if you are of if you are going into this
thinking well core has to be in love
with somebody but but that's exit
exactly what you said the Omegas Lobby
has said no the idea is she has to be in
love with somebody it's like I I don't
care people are in love with anybody
that's fine but it's like it seems so
out of nowhere now the blue and if this
happened middle season Sunday be fine
but like you said I tend to agree with
they probably wouldn't be able to get
away with that so to me this is sort of
like their pigeon they're pigeon holed
by the sponge no sissy punsch demand
certain things and lesbian loves not
doing a lesbian love story I'm sure was
one of them like I I'm sure if they
wanted to do a lesbian like weary from
the beginning or develop this out and
they're gonna be really truly in love
and you're gonna see all of this I'm
sure this funny right and then like beat
them to death so it you it's like the
1963 haunting we love that movie how
ridiculous is their movie from a modern
perspective like with the fact that the
lesbian subtext is so buried to the
point that's like you know just come out
and say it like but that's the way it
worked back in the olden day no effing
way no no but we wouldn't get even that
is a little that still works in the
context of the story though because in
my opinion that still works too they're
in a place they're scared and she
doesn't know if they're actually hugging
together like they're afraid or she's
even coming on to her that makes her
more you know scared because she's not
gay so that just adds another level of
awkwardness and uncomfortableness for
the main character who's already playing
ratio to put our main characters of the
haunted house yes but no III say it's
kind of like like let's say they do the
last x-men movie like and there's Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine whatever
everything's done and they defeat
everybody and he looks at storm and says
let's take a vacation together and she
says okay and they kiss it's like it
there's nothing wrong there anything but
where that come from but there was no
reason you couldn't have built their
romance up from the beginning there is
here but that okay but that's why I feel
the sponge whoa no but that's not me
ethically I think it's a big step
storytelling why I saw it as a gimmick
for a good reason what you're saying and
this is cuz I had the same thing I feel
exactly the same way which is it it
didn't serve too much for the main plot
they were hints dropped and Brava them
for the hints I picked up on it so I
mean clearly they had some concept I'm
not convinced they knew season 1 they
were doing this no I I'm convinced that
somewhere probably in the middle of
writing season 2 they started to hatch
this idea in their head and I'm sure
that they were just like this no way
Nick's gonna go for this are you freakin
kidding me we got to somehow be subtle
and pull this out at the last second
before they're just force Nick's hand to
be like okay don't run the finale see
what the fans say then what and the
fight thing too it's like oh yeah with
the gimme gets kinda like all the people
that are against it I just love the idea
you know the shows fun there's going
there with a just like oh she was my
bitches like just all of us just so you
were watching a by character the whole
time so oh yeah so advancing on the one
hand yes I would have liked to have seen
a real lesbian love story this was a
puppy love lesbian love story like oh
it's fun and kind of out of nowhere you
know like okay not not totally out of
nowhere because they were hints so that
is the actual problem with the story I
agree with you outside of not doing it
at all and it seems clear they wanted to
do it what is your other option you
don't have one oh no I'm not saying I
necessarily do the problem obviously
double-edged sword mace has happened at
all and like I said I hate the fact I
have to be amazed by that but I'm glad
that it did happen it didn't like and
like say it didn't ruin anything it's
not like all those finales now I'm in
saying I think we have more chemistry
than my core it did to be go yeah or an
Asami and you know it is fun but maybe
that again is all I'm knocked for muck
well and the funny thing is like you
know you brought up like hey you maybe
there's a little something you're doing
calve it's a joke it's like there
definitely was once yeah whichever what
episode I
bring it believed it I didn't think they
were gonna go all out with it I think
they wanted to I never thought there
definitely wasn't going to state and I
camera was but there was definitely a
line where Asami says something that has
a very like I can't see that being taken
any other way than you know she's a
lesbian you know kind of thing but like
I said I mean you want those things
where it's like I like me saying we it
would have been nice to see it developed
more but it's like but when we decided
to take this show to make this big step
I live in 21st century in America we
live in 21st century America and
apparently this is good as we can get
yeah so it's I hope it opens up more I
hope more is done with this and there
can be you know in gay Bibles on Japan I
mean doing technical free even yeah I
mean it's like it's it would be nice I
mean a little bit okay
I just you like a steerable about myself
so anyway uh but no it's one of those
things where it's like I really hope
this opens up a lot and it's on the one
hand and I'm really happy people are
like oh isn't this incredible so that's
an a little finale and but you know what
I mean it's like I'm failing well no
okay from their sleep their second day
you wait there's gonna be a group of
people like us and we're gonna be a
small group who are going to be this was
not the greatest thing on the planet
because they didn't do enough but we
realize the reason why they didn't do
enough so I'm not blaming them for that
yeah and it's still kind of a little
more and then there's also a group
that's just gonna be like I can't
believe they you know freakin did that
that's so stupid and like who cares if
they're you know and I'm like I don't
think you realize this subset of people
what a big deal this actually is some
people just like who cares don't even
talk about I'm like no this is actually
legitimately a really big deal and the
other people that are just like it's a
greatest thing in the world I'm like no
we could have gotten a lot more actually
but Nickelodeon there's no way in hell
they would have women hey yeah I think I
used to be one of those people that was
kind of like well if you are great if
you're not great who cares kind of thing
so I would originally can't be on that
site but again it just after seeing it's
like that prejudice is still out there
man you know it's like I wish I could
say no it's not you can't think to
yourself well I don't act this way so
clearly nobody else acts this way
the representation of my facebook was
like oh my god I can't believe it this
is no I have to look forward to my kids
having to watch like ball torture and
BDSM and their cartoons I was like oh
yeah
I'm like this better better than
spongebob well first of all because
those two things go so handy yeah I only
a true love story you know and freaking
like fetishism I like all the gay people
I know as soon as I find out they're gay
I'm like okay so where's the ball gag
all right here in my pocket
and the joke's on you people because
they will need to watch in their
cartoons they can just write about it on
the Internet fan fiction seriously
everybody who freaks out with this I
can't believe I got yes gets cut down
yes god I can't believe I'm like they
can go online and create their own more
horrific world where dipper goes to Taco
I can't believe we're in a world where
two women love each other now go back to
your divorced parents that takes up
whatever like 60 80 percent of marriages
that's it drink another scotch
so are you two women who are in love so
they look moms popping the oxycontin
that's true off but yeah so that that's
where I'm coming from I'm like it is
both not the biggest deal in the world
story wise because I've seen Japanese
animes that do this you know way more
over the top than this but at the same
time it is really a big deal and I don't
I think they probably had this planned
out from about the middle of season two
I would say three I would say three
maybe three it depends how far ahead
they're writing these but it just makes
me laugh because all I think the thing
that makes you laugh the most is all the
people who were against shipping these
characters why does everybody have to
shit why does it why can't that to care
that's one of the reasons I did talk
about cuz everyone's gonna be like Oh
perv like that's what all you men want
what do you think it's almost like the
creator's read this and it just like a
little fuck with these guys let's troll
oh please and like it makes me laugh cuz
like I all the people who were so upset
about the shipping vanished from my fav
my public Facebook overnight
I ain't seen anything from them I'm just
like where did they go so I yeah that
just kills me but they shit I'm like
it's like they look down they're just
like oh so let's see what do we got
going on here well we know where this
love story's going everybody wants these
two characters put together man that's
gonna create a giant uproar you it I got
it we'll ship ourselves let's do it well
I love it it's almost trolling if they
may be trolling I don't know if trolling
for a good cause or parking I but it's
just like yeah I feel like the audience
just like half the audience that were is
against this whole thing just totally
got trolled and for the rest it was just
like we made their fanfic names come
true well and was I gonna say like uh
I'm against the no can't really mm-hmm
have like yeah you're kind of you're
kind of outed but not sure as what in
that case um so but okay so we got that
all said out of the way um let's talk
about the rest of it did anything else
happen Isis assists no I just I just
kept rewinding that last ten seconds
again and again and again I've got it a
loop now uh as you the funny thing is
going into that wonderful ten seconds
I've seen now for three hours straight
um the rest of the episode I thought was
really really solid it was a good finale
I appreciate it most was the teamwork
that took yes everybody though I will
say I've watched it with my wife and I
turned to her in the middle of it and I
said where's Marco like I noticed where
whether all these people flying I was
like what happened to Marco and then he
shows up with Bolin on the inside there
and my wife's like there he is
that's my
okay no she he had a good no he
sacrifices a good say avail by having
bowling come back as well - very very
good you learned a very Return of the
Jedi let's go into the Death Star blow
it up from its evil heart out yeah um
the animation is great I love water
balloon they're the the paint balloons I
thought was in the second he's like aha
paint I was like I got it out there
doing so I thought that was a great idea
I also like that she had a means of
getting rid of that with a little window
washer whatever that was
damnit windshield wipers she thought of
everything this is so no I thought it
was um like it seemed to get bigger and
bigger aw man
redemption for a sound he's dad yes okay
you know how she came in see no no when
he came in like I said I love a show
that can make me gasp and I did that you
go oh I like I like it a good way like
oh it's awesome again and it's like now
of course immediately after he came back
by giving along I'm like dad you are so
gone yes let me ride together
but please paint the target on my head
this is ya know I thought that was a
great seat I I do have to say this
though like I let the technology is kind
of cool it's to me it's very it got kind
of steampunk ish in this episode in
particular it's always been kind of
steampunk but then this one like those
hummingbird crafts
we're very steampunk but it it made me
laugh cuz I'm just like yes this is a
brilliant scientific idea let's expend
so much effing energy to make a couple
of wings go like this makes no sense
gotta be other ways alright I looked at
Mike it looks really cool doesn't really
make any sense but yeah I'm like or how
about a jet engine that's okay now you
all know the really funny thing before
the korra and asami thing I was really
debating whether or not I want to see
Varrick and Julie together
um because I saw a dance like okay it's
not like you can't see it happen but on
the other hand outs are like what's this
more of a partnership I mean they did
have like a lot in common obviously the
worked with you always thought it is a
kind of an abusive relationship I mean
he comes around but it's like is that
really the best basis the funny thing is
every for everybody you sing like corn
Asami fell for us I probably
felt the Julie and varrick thing felt a
little more force just because I got the
impression throughout the entire series
that both of them were asexual beings
like that wasn't get it is kind of true
you never associate romance with them it
was like two plants interacting I never
saw any real romance like yeah so I was
Julie recently they were kind of kicking
it in but I'm like yeah I guess I'm just
looking like why does she
I get why she'd be impressed by his
idiot savant genius or maybe want to be
as far to but I was like why does she
love him the only thing I can't figure
is like she sees like quote-unquote the
good in him because he does come around
and stuff like that but yeah I'm kind of
the same way Innokin Callas isn't all I
said if it was not that there's no
comedy if it clearly is but like that
wedding like they show the wedding in
great detail and I'm thinking okay no
they're meant to show I could really
love this is not just a joke like
they're legitimately in love and and
there's a bunch of jokes thrown in but
it's supposed to be like a real thing so
I was kind of like yeah okay I guess
like I'm not anti that but at the same
time I was like does it
I'm just waiting I'm just waiting that
now that the creators have like
confirmed that this is real korrasami um
now the fanfic writers are gonna have to
ship something else so they're gonna try
to ship maybe Julie Dora and maybe I'm
making this big love triangle like a
soap opera and this is love square or
whatever um love love dodecagon
everybody gets involved buddy so yeah
and like I said I can't get like I can't
get too angry at like you know this
romance coming on no we're not like
seeing it develop more cos like you know
they dict us around with Zuko's mom you
know and they eventually came around the
comics and stuff so it's like I'm kind
of thinking myself well yeah I'd like to
see these two go on an adventure
together develop more and you know it's
obviously not doing any more show so
it's like yeah get working on that comic
it's like I I'm not against a
relationship with them I'm very much
like to see it but I like to see it
develop do I like to see it really put
together redemption for Bolin like this
was a great bull in episode he liked the
the lava like sucking them
robot into the this and the last season
I thought were both great there were
good Bolin seasons honestly yeah I
thought he really came from Bolin they
had a lot of great moments you know
getting the people out you know saving
mock Oh at the end like yeah I'm just
like good Bolin finally gets his dues he
won't balances out like he's still funny
but he likes represent yeah oh um I try
think what else I mean it's like I like
okay I'll tell you what I like I like
the fact that the only way core goes
into the Avatar state this time around
is to save a life and not take it yeah
at yeah I like picture cuz I was sort of
saying like what there's a couple times
you could go into the Avatar state why
doesn't she
and only does it if I save kuvira's life
mm-hmm I waited the talk bringing kuvira
around is like come on you got mommy
shoes and then identity is Jesus who
stole all right and she's like if I turn
myself in it nobody's like you know okay
won't just as the same it's like you're
so fucking gonna bake you you which I
mean it's like I understand of all I
need yeah anyway yeah the thing she
turned over so quickly is kind of like I
don't know would would Hitler turn over
so quickly with who said sadi I was just
having some fun I was guessing with
who's saying but I guess he did like it
soon as they had the guns on and they
found him he's just like you know I'm
willing to compromise a lot we usually
know Hitler wouldn't have change that
fast he would just kill himself yeah
dish so yes ma kuvira d obviously took
the high road I guess you can think of
joke we're two just a big joke he's very
funny dude too soon too soon so um yeah
a really good finale um I I think we
pretty much got into as much detail as
we can about the another spirit portal I
did love Tenzin's observations it's like
Korra you've done more in like four
seasons of the show than Aang didn't
like his entire life like me not gonna
like that's actually he's totally
weirded pointles activeness
yeah there is like she's not as good as
Aang I'm like well she's got a lot more
accomplished yeah I mean let's really
look at what she did for the world I
mean it's like I know I get it fair
enough but say yeah be different the
fire oh that's fun she stopped like four
villains yeah got like one yeah well and
it's like okay granted it was a big one
it was the world but it's like what yeah
there was a zoo on her circus troupe but
you know it is still mostly one no but
it's like yeah with uh with core hits
like when you said I'm like that's a
really good point they have all the
portals that open up the spirit world
and make you happy had to do with inside
information from the villains own kid so
so I thought that was a very legit point
I need a win so I guess she's not as
good it's like it is no fucking Turtles
sister what the turtle though oh I
thought I was thinking like Ninja
Turtles or some reason like it's a lion
turtle Rob you have to be more clear and
only all I'm lion Turtles littles
what it's early in the morning I need
coffee it's just that so okay we're
gonna go get some coffee that is the
last core v-log again as far as we know
as I could I know what you a whole show
together I like the whole show
yeah everything uh I really liked it I
think it's very clear they did not have
or were given a plan for the whole thing
and you lied for what they had to do and
get through there's obviously bumps uh
it's um much more noticeable than others
but it's like it's an impressive show uh
and I don't like as much as avatar but
there are points that I do like just as
much if not a little bit more like a
good wine at aged better over time
yeah like while they were making it
though yeah it I the first season I
still stand by as for what it wasn't
like you have one shot at this one
season and you're done I thought it was
fine like the ending the last five
minutes could have been better but I
thought it was really strong season and
then yeah Nickelodeon's dicking it
around it's like yes and I still stand
by has we had as characters yes I have a
villain we had three seasons of
Nickelodeon dicking them around and I'm
amazed it came out as well as it did i
magic blown away that these guys kept it
together despite all the corporate you
know tooling you know trying to destroy
it so
and yeah it was a bumpy ride I think
second season was definitely weakest as
they were trying to rewrite this from
the ground up
seems like second season to me probably
should have been the first police and
possession season also has am I being
like the most memorable people so it's
like I can't be that angry it has like
one of the most memorable climax is to
you know say and the origin story so
it's like as bumpy as the second season
was it has some of the most memorable
snow remember una lock that well I
better not the villain I'm talking about
the twins I'm talking about very
casually out talking about him remember
stirrer winds are sad yeah but Varrick
and Julie were throughout the whole
thing so another one in the first season
no I mean okay from but from second
season on that's not saying a second
season introduced when they introduced
that the best but the story itself was
also a train wreck like it went and it
came together very nicely at the end and
then yeah I'd say third season by third
season they were getting it together
like okay I think we know where we're
going with this and fourth season I just
think this is not as close as pitch
perfect as I think it gets like yeah my
favorite season yeah yeah might also
where they did the most with Cora
herself like everything we had talked
about really consequences for actions
you need her to go through a spiritual
journey and this and that they did it
and they did it well so wait a way to go
out on top
despite a decade I think the colognian
is done to stop them from doing it way
to go out on top and you got the first
bisexual main character in a kid show so
I mean it's like time to come out on top
and like make monster is amazing oh but
you could be who knows um but no the
fact that they not only do they come out
on top but they also pretty much make
history with the show that's wonderful
you know it's just the hats off man
you know nicely taught so I enjoyed it
I'm I'm glad it's done I feel like a
fair citizens we've had our fill well
I'm no break in between the third and
fourth it just went right it's part of
it I'm like I didn't feel exhausted
after avatar the original show this this
one I'm like I'm getting a little
fatigued here and I don't think that's
on the creator's I think that's on the
fact that like they just there was no
break so I couldn't like take a breather
I was like oh my god we're still going
with this so but it it's good to be done
but I'm really
yeah when we got through it all and
enjoyed it and um I think - it also may
be a little fatigued just cuz it was so
suspenseful particularly at the end like
I didn't realize it during the Mafia
robot fight I was actually gritting my
teeth a bit until I like sort of like
yawned and I'm like oh that's really
intense I did the one scene I actually
liked in The Hobbit was when Smaug
attacks the city I did the same thing my
wife yeah my wife is like you're
squeezing my hand really hard I'm like
no I'm like it just was like such an
intense enums yeah yeah so so come here
what Oh in terms of our v-log shows
we're obviously doing gravity falls
after that like it oming knows right
after this yeah I mean after that we're
not actively looking kinda like what we
said the last I think we should do
something comes up we'll do it uh I do
we're gonna do the gravity falls shorts
okay sure yeah sasai enough people keep
asking us I say we do that and they're
short obviously so one yeah well we'll
fill in some of the gaps so then I think
we should do over the garden wall at
some point yeah I haven't seen that yet
but everyone's tell me it's really good
but that's like a movie right it's like
eight episodes so it's a minis but
something we could toss off quickly so
okay I didn't know is it I can eat up to
something I started out every morning
like so everyone saw me to review it you
like gravity falls okay okay
leave me alone it's Christmas said I
need coffee
so cuoco we're gonna get some coffee and
we'll see you next video
take care Cheers Appa did you know she
was by I had my thoughts by the way I'm
bi Oh
get to your fanfiction Oh